[Music]
hanging at my cat Raskin I'm here at
cute Connie you walking the floor and
I'm here with Camilla from gitlab
Camilla how are you doing today okay I'm
quite busy actually we first we actually
talking with a lot of people they are
very interested in our kubernetes
integration that we started offering and
there is also a lot of work and a lot of
very nice ideas about the feature that
we want to introduce so basically we are
able to meet with people to discuss the
power plants and what they actually do
it's all so tell me a bit more about get
lab what are some of the things that get
lab currently does we actually spent a
lot of time trying to be the best on
DevOps we introduced Auto DevOps which
kind of follows this trend of being very
good integrated integrated with the
kubernetes basically simplifying
interaction with the cupola - because
kubernetes by itself it's great product
but it's also quite complex - people
starting using that we have this Q by PI
server we have this deployment manifest
then we have the ham
these are not easy things to to teach if
they're line learning curve is quite
high but without a DevOps we simplify
all of that into set of conventions and
our implementation of this convention so
you can like start right like that you
just push your application to get up we
test your application we perform
security scanning we create container
image of your application post to
container registry then provide your
staging and production environments and
like actually when you
even go to like our kubernetes
integration you just click button login
to Google to your google cloud and maybe
as I attach your credit card and in like
five minutes you have 14 kubernetes
cluster and we are working applications
maybe the application that is based on
the beat parks that are Heroku Ephraim
is providing so I can deploy it directly
from get lab to communities engine
exactly right it's amazing it's like
it's not it's even more like directly
from github using google cloud to call
Metis engine so like we try to remove
all the barriers on deploying your
application you just care about your
application you don't care about the
before source you don't care about the
containers you care about the
application you care about the workflow
you care about the practices something
that I know that this is probably one of
the most requested questions that we
have not like what is the best practice
to work with the kubernetes Thanks
there is so much technology right now in
the market and so many different ideas
that people are basically lost and and
we try to solve that each trying to help
people out yes salvors okay thank you
and anything else you want to talk about
here while we're here at Q Khan we have
like very big plans for the CI
integration when I get love there are a
lot of things happening for example I
spent time with our contributor like
right before this this conversation
about the next upcoming feature for the
CI which is like ability to debarked
jobs life using the web terminal
something that is becoming
but a fundaments to web ID that we are
right now working on that got introduced
I think in 10.7 and it's gonna be
introducing ten point I'd and web ID is
actually quite cool it because consider
that you start usually we have this time
Nancy like we open our time in re
opening our vs code or some other idea
on our computers and we start writing we
come it goes maybe we run some tests but
let's say that we don't need that like
let's say that you have your computer
which is terminal like terminal to the
to the wall to the cloud and you use
that directly like you just open browser
we just progressed on you everything we
just give you the source code we
provision your environment world space
where you can work on much bigger
machines that you're like lightweight
MacBook right so it makes it's actually
way easier faster because it's much
easier to switch between between
different workspaces so between
different tasks and like remove you from
trying to do all these heavy-duty
operations on your computer which are
like today it's kind of underpowered
like beat up itself we are running 20 is
7000 has ever ever comment so like it's
crazy when you try to run that locally
so we basically try to use the power of
the github and github CI and web ID and
the terminal integration to put that
everything into cloud where you can have
basically unlimited resources and if you
consider that you can use that with the
kubernetes and Google Cloud something
that we offer it makes it basically kind
of infinite scalable solution that we
are never limited by anything
thank you so much Camille thank you hope
y'all I hope you're having a good cute
con right now it's amazing okay and to
all those watching I hope you're
enjoying watching these videos of us a
cube con we'll see you in Seattle